the russian invasion is yet to reach
odessa
but here there's a feeling that it's
just a matter of time and not much
longer to wait
[Applause]
president vladimir zelinsky has called
on all ukrainians to join the war effort
and people like andrei harlamov who's an
opera singer have answered his call it's
uglier
for 10 maybe 20 yeah
he thinks that it's going to be a long
war despite ongoing negotiation
and complaints that ukraine has been
left to fight alone
they didn't want to help us right now
they promised weapons more active
involvement in the war fighter jets
now the us is refusing and biden hasn't
delivered they are not closing the sky
they are not taking away russia's
ability to bomb our peaceful cities and
annihilate women children and the
elderly they are not protecting the
humanitarian corridors from mario paul
the city is frantically building its
defenses civic organizers say they have
so far filled more than 400 000 sandbags
odessa is under threat from several
fronts
the russian army
is trying to advance from the south
while russian warships
are said to be approaching the coast but
it won't be so easy because the city is
heavily fortified
long stretches of the shoreline have
been laid with landmines to delay any
beach landing
capturing this port city would give
russia control of the black sea and
landlocked ukraine
back in town the air siren goes off day
and night but the city hasn't been
directly hit
the sandbags made at the beach surround
cultural and municipal buildings
and kyrie lipatov tells me about the
efforts to preserve odessa's cultural
treasures
we're talking about saving the heritage
ukrainian european russian it doesn't
matter we're saving art
the museum in harkief was bombed and
sadly the collection there was mostly
lost
there's something that has been
bothering me a lot though ukrainian
museums have to protect masterpieces of
russian art from the russian aggression
it is a paradox we want the world to
know about that
odessa has long been the pride of russia
it was founded by catherine the great
the city has embraced its russian
identity ever since
but with a war looming those voices have
gone all but silent and odessa that was
saved by the soviets during world war ii
is now getting ready to defend itself
from his former protectors
al jazeera odessa ukraine